bonjour à tous c'est l'heure de
parlement hebdo le meilleur de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
sur lcp public sénat avec mickey la nef
au georgia et on va passer au titre
numéro un de cette semaine on va revenir
sur cette primaire ils ont débattu
pendant deux heures et demie sur
l'économie sur la sécurité sur les
affaires judiciaires aussi en toile de
fond avantage alain juppé pour ce débat
dans l'actualité aussi cette semaine le
budget 2010 est qui est bien arrivé à
l'assemblée examiné en commission ce
dernier budget du quinquennat contient
des baisses d'impôts et instaure
notamment le prélèvement pour tous sur
la fiche de paye et puis un sujet de
société qui divise aussi les
parlementaires faut-il légaliser ou non
la consommation de cannabis la question
était l'objet d'un colloque au sénat
notre invité ont parlé cette semaine de
toute cette actualité c'est jean
christophe lagarde qui est présidente de
lui dit vous avez annoncé cette semaine
votre ralliement à la gpe évidemment on
va beaucoup parler de cette primaire et
oui six hommes et une femme devant les
caméras et un grand favori à l'issue
chacun avait son programme sa stratégie
on va commencer par écouter bruno le
maire et nicolas sarkozy on a gouverné
ensemble pendant cinq ans et on a eu à
faire face à la crise la plus violente
que le monde ait jamais connue depuis
si vous voulez que tout continue comme
avant
eh bien vous avez tout ce qu'il faut sur
ce plateau mais si vous voulez que cela
change vraiment alors choisissez le
renouveau voilà et puis alain juppé est
largement ressorti gagnant de ce premier
débat télévisé pour 36% des sondés c'est
le vainqueur de ce premier débat c'est
un sondage sofres pour lci le figaro et
public sénat
réalisée le 14 octobre là vous voyez ce
sondage et puis vous voyez que bruno le
maire et françois fillon arrive avec 11%
jeu christophe lagarde
sont ils tous comptables du bilan du
quinquennat précédent toutes les
personnes que vous avez vu hier soir sur
le débat évidemment on sait bien dans un
dans la vème république que le chef sait
que chef de l'état il est élu par tous
les français c'est lui qui décide même
le premier ministre on l'a vu ces
dernières années on l'a vu quand c'était
nicolas sarkozy
on le voit aussi sous françois hollande
même le premier ministre essaye de faire
valoir son opinion mais finalement c'est
le tchad et à qui tranche il n'y a pas
mal roseaux table c'est nicolas sarkozy
pour vous mais bien évidemment enfin
vous pouvez pas être le chef et ensuite
dire je ne suis pas comptable et les
zones sont responsables autant que moi
sinon vous n'êtes pas le chef prière on
l'a bien entendu nicolas sarkozy il a
dit nous avons tous gouverner ensemble
c'est de la technique c'est de la
technique politique mais la réalité
enfin est ce qu'il ya un français qui
pensent que quelqu'un a décidé autrement
que nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs un moment
donné il dit à jean françois copé
tu n'étais pas en mesure de nous imposer
quoi que ce soit circulez y'a rien à
boire j'étais le chef
je me souviens même que il avait dû dire
de son premier disque que c'était son
collaborateur est ce que vous considérez
que vos collaborateurs sont comptables
de vos erreurs
jean christophe lagarde vous étiez vous
avez assisté sur le plateau à ce premier
débat comment avez vous trouvé celui que
vous soutenez alain juppé comme on
l'avait trouvé de bron convaincant je
les trouvais à la fois solides on voit
quelqu'un qui tient
entre guillemets les dossiers qui les
connaît déterminé et serein et d'une
certaine façon l'impression que j'en
avais à la sortie c'est que il ya ceux
qui s'agitent naturellement il ya ceux
qui s'agitent un peu pour se faire
remarquer parce que c'est aussi le lot
des petits candidats et il dégage et
finalement l'impression d'un vrai chef
pas besoin de s'agiter pour avoir
d'autorité ça convient à votre famille
politique c'est ce que recherche
finalement votre famille politique non
ma famille politique elle cherche un
projet et une coalition qui permet en
l'occurrence de gouverner la france
parce que notre défi c'est bien sur
l'alternance mais ces deux là réussir et
pour la réussir il faut pas se condamner
à l'impuissance comme ça a été le cas de
2002 à 2012 où on n'a pas pu réduire les
déficits réduire le chômage redresser
l'éducation nationale et pour ça il ya
besoin d'additionner des forces
politiques parce qu'on peut avoir la
majorité ici dans cette maison à
l'assemblée nationale avec seulement un
français sur quatre
quand on regarde bien des résultats des
élections et on peut pas gouverner et on
veut pas transformer la france avec
trois français sur quatre qui n'adhèrent
pas à ce que vous faites est ce que vous
avez vu ans alain juppé le candidat du
centre hier soir c'est le candidat de la
droite excusez moi alain juppé est un
candidat de droite mais qui est
compatible avec le centre et surtout qui
a accepté cette idée de rassemblement de
coalition d'additionner des gens
différents qui se retroussent les
manches pour faire redémarrer la france
la france est le seul pays en panne en
europe
nous sommes dans le paradoxe le chef de
l'état français c'est celui qui de tous
les chefs d'état occidentaux qui a le
plus de points pardon de pouvoir et le
moins de contre-pouvoir et c'est le seul
pays le nôtre qui n'arrive pas à se
transformer à se réformer
parce qu'à chaque fois ceux qui
gouvernent ont socialement une base trop
étroite et moi je pense qu additionner
des forces politiques des forces
sociales différentes c'est le moyen de
surmonter des corporatismes les blocages
de la société française c'est ça qui
nous fait prendre beaucoup n'avaient pas
été sur le plateau pour dire tout ça
pourquoi n'avait pas participé à cette
primaire parce que moi je rêvais de voir
l'aurait plus longtemps ce genre parce
que j'aurais répondu clairement non à
une des questions à quel est ce que vous
soutenez le candidat quel qu'il soit non
je ne soutiens pas le candidat quel
qu'il soit pour une raison si c'est
nicolas sarkoz rue des gens très sympas
pour une raison très simple c'est que
s'engager dans la primaire c'est le
choix qu'a fait le congrès de lui dit
c'était accepter par avance le résultat
c'est à dire accepter le programme d'un
candidat sans même qu'on puisse
contester par exemple vous me parlez de
nicolas sarkozy je suis totalement
opposé nous sommes totalement opposés à
la remise en cause du droit du sol le
droit du sol depuis la 3ème république
contrairement à ce qu'il a dit ça fait
partie de l'identité nationale ça fait
partie de l'identité de la garde var
dans sa salle est parti ça fait partie
de l'identité républicaine
d'ailleurs j'ai entendu un autre
candidat je ne sais plus lequel dire je
crois que c'est jean françois copé dire
si on est en france de parents étrangers
même si on est là et qu'on n'a pas connu
un autre pays on devient pas français
sociaux telles et telles conditions
pardon si un jeune qui a 16 ans ou 17
ans et délinquants alors qu'il est né en
france qu'il était allé à l'école
française qu'il est passé entre les
mains de la justice française du système
social français
si ce jeune là est un délinquant c'est
la faute de ces deux de son pays
d'origine en fait la faute de serment
sadc la faute de ses parents un c'est la
faute de ses parents et c'est là au
temps du pardon je termine ma phrase
c'est la faute de ses parents et c'est
la faute des institutions qui n'ont pas
su éviter cette dérive je reviens là que
vous avez dit parce que c'est important
si jamais nicolas sarkozy et le candidat
vous ne le soutiendrai pas je viens de
dire que je ne soutiendrai pas
automatiquement le vainqueur de la
primaire vous pensez nicolas sarkozy je
peux vous en citer d'autres
et quand nous avons pris cette décision
à l'époque il y avait des gens comme
nadine morano qui était candidat vous
nous imaginez en train de soutenir me
les autres il est parmi les compositions
sont un peuple ça mais il y en a un
certain nombre mais moi je soutiens un
candidat et je ne souhaite pas entre
être embarqué c'est ce que nous avons
décidé nous avons décidé d'être libre
elle vendra un candidat nous avons
décidé d'être libres avant pendant et
après la primaire il y aura un candidat
centriste et je répondrai ces questions
si l'hypothèse survient mais il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui ce qui me paraît
nécessaire c'est d'avoir un candidat qui
soit incapable de rassembler deux pieds
la compétence la détermination et la
sérénité et 3 qui ne se laisse pas
embarquer par les modes qui ne cherchent
pas pardon on ne le dit jamais à
gouverner pour les huit jours qui
viennent pour faire plaisir aux médias
et à l'opinion publique
or alain juppé a le courage par exemple
de dire que puisque nous vivons dollar
puisque nous vivons de plus en plus
longtemps
et puisque nous étudions de plus en plus
longtemps on peut pas travailler moins
longtemps et qu'il va falloir allonger
la durée de la retraite c'est pas facile
de dire ça des français c'est courageux
des français mais à force d'avoir manqué
de courage on a mis la france dans la
situation dans laquelle elle est il a le
courage de dire des vérités qui sont pas
agréables à entendre mais qui sont
nécessaires à la france est nécessaire à
nos enfants
et la réponse que j'ai le plus apprécié
chez lui c'est si on essaye de réduire
le déficit budgétaire
c'est pas pour faire plaisir aux
banquiers c'est pas pour faire plaisir à
l'europe
c'est juste parce qu'il en a marre de
notre pays notre génération refile ses
factures à ses enfants
2200 milliards de dettes qu'on leur a
collé sur la tête avec quoi père ont-ils
leur propre besoin de policiers
d'enseignants ou de santé on va avancer
dans cette émission puisque en toile de
fond de ces débats ont été évoqués de
nombreuses affaires judiciaires
alain juppé notamment s'est justifié sur
son cas personnel écoutez je tiens mon
casier judiciaire à la disposition de
bruno il est connu d'ailleurs que le
monde connaît la condamnation qui m'a
été infligée aujourd'hui les français
ont la décision au bout de leurs
bulletins de vote
s'il estime que ma faute me disqualifie
ils ne mèneront pas ce que vous en
pensez jean christophe lagarde est ce
que vous pensez qu'alain juppé a été
convaincant dans sa défense est ce que
les français ont oublié ce qui est
arrivé je crois que les français n'ont
rien oublié que comme il le dit
décideront si sa faute
j'y mets des guillemets moi je ne suis
pas de cette famille politique mais je
vais quand même dire ce que je pense
tout le monde sait qu'alain juppé a été
condamné pour jacques chirac tout le
monde sait qu'alain juppé a accepté de
se sacrifier
par fidélité à l'homme qui dirigeait la
mairie de paris qui n'était en rien
responsable d'un système qui était
généralisé qui était partagée d'ailleurs
dans beaucoup de parties à l'époque
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas encore les
financements et dont le public un stade
et qui permettent aujourd'hui aux
parties de vivre de vivre chichement
mais de vivre normalement et donc je
trouve que c'est courageux de sa part
d'abord d'avoir à l'époque accepté de
prendre sur lui ce qui n'était pas de sa
responsabilité
et les français savent bien je crois que
ça fait une vingtaine d'années ce qui
s'est passé il a purgé il a perdu tous
ses mandats il a été obligé de partir
mais au canada il a payé et beaucoup de
français qui ont commis des erreurs dans
leur vie ils savent aussi que quand on
n'est sanctionné on paye sa faute et
ensuite on peut ouvrir une nouvelle page
de sa vie à la roma accueillera bientôt
dans un instant maintenant notre
partenaire du scan
c'est un leurre de jim jarrassé
bonjour jim bonjour ni kale borroka cha
bonjour jean christophe lagarde joue on
va essayer d'y voir ensemble un peu plus
clair sur vos positions concernant la
primaire à d'autres parce que on va voir
c'est pas évident et on a du mal à tout
comprendre
vous avez déjà d'abord décidé de ne pas
prendre parti dans la primaire à droite
puis vous avez de ne pas engager deux
candidats ne pas engager prétendit
d'atlanta fait la même chose ce qui va
poser un vrai appelé au dialogue avec
emmanuel macron avec lequel vous disiez
avoir des convergences
ensuite vous désormais désormais vous
soutenez alain juppé et vous dénoncez
les postures des manuels macron est ce
que vous pouvez un peu nous expliquer la
cohérence de ses choix succès c'est
d'abord je ne sais pas où vous avez vu
j'aurais dénoncé les postures des médias
sur rtl cette semaine
pardon monsieur c'est absolument pas ce
que j'ai dit je reviens dans l'ordre
première chose je comprends que vous
ayez du mal à comprendre parce que moi
je suis contre la politique réflexe
contre la politique pavlovienne c'est à
dire on est censé rester dans sa petite
case comme on a envie sans avoir pensé
il se trouve que nous avons refusé
oui d'engager un candidat dans la
primaire je viens d'expliquer pourquoi
parce que nous ne voulions pas être
pieds et poings liés on n'a jamais dit
qu'on ne se prononcerait pas on a
simplement dit qu'on allait regarder le
débat on a examiné les programmes
rencontrer des candidats ça a été très
utile d'ailleurs pour éclaircir un
certain nombre de sujets et le travail
n'est pas terminé puisqu'il faut
maintenant construire une plate forme
législative et y compris les gens qui
étaient sur le plateau hier vont devoir
pour une partie d'entre eux ce qu'ils
n'arrêteront pas le coma public se
retrouvaient sur une plateforme
initiative nous aussi pardon première
étape deuxième étape
à la rentrée il ya un événement qui se
produit emmanuel macron ministre de
l'économie dont la droite le centre
disait le plus grand bien lorsqu'il
était ministre de l'économie parce qu'il
disait des choses différentes de la
majorité socialiste disant les choses
décide de quitter le gouvernement de
rompent avec françois hollande le pire
président de la cinquième république et
du subitement la droite et le sentier
même ce qui faisait profession de 2,2
comment dirais-je d'expliquer qu'il
fallait qu'on dialogue tout le monde du
cloud kaka porte au nez moi je dis que
nous avions et nous avons vocation à
dialoguer avec quelqu'un qui m'a marqué
c'est toujours d'actualité
il est de centre gauche certes mais il
ya des choses qui dit et qui sont
communes à ce qui se disait hier soir
sur le plateau
la remise en cause du statut attendait
soyons clair parce que j'en ai marre
mois qu'on fasse semblant d'accord la
remise en cause du statut des
fonctionnaires
il ya beaucoup de candidats qui étaient
en train de le porter je pense
qu'effectivement sur certains éléments
de fonction publique il n'y a pas de
raison que un agent d'accueil dans un
service municipal et un agent d'accueil
dans une entreprise n'est pas le même
statut parce qu'ils font la même
fonction ce que vous happe et alain
juppé a dirigé avec lui et donc jeudi à
juppé est assez grands pour savoir ce
qu'il aura à faire mais moi je
continuerai si ça intéresse à emmanuel
macron à dialoguer parce que quand il ya
des points de convergence dans la
politique française faut pas faire
semblant d'être en désaccord
sinon qu'est ce qui va se passer
j'espère qu'alain juppé pourra à la fois
gagner la primaire et gagner l'élection
présidentielle et au lendemain de
l'élection présidentielle monsieur macro
serait obligé de dire le contraire de ce
qu'il racontait quand il était au
gouvernement juste pour être dans
l'opposition comme les socialistes l'ont
fait mais gêné gardons autre livre hier
on parlait de retraite comme les
socialistes l'ont fait quand il ya eu la
réforme des retraites de 2010 ils
manifestaient il expliquait alors à
revenir en arrière
vous allez voir ils arrivent au pouvoir
ils font le contraire les français en
ont marre vous êtes les races et en en
marre qu'on fasse semblant je vous
espérez qu'alain juppé va l'emporter
mais cécile nicolas sarkozy l'emportent
qu'est-ce qui se passe
est ce que vous allez soutenir par
exemple françois bayrou si les candidats
j'ai tout à l'heure répondu à cette
question j'y répondrai le 27 novembre si
le cas se présente je n'y répondrai pas
avant est-ce que choisir alain juppé ce
n'est pas aussi favoriser le retour d'un
de françois bayrou donc jeu politique
qui est du coup en grand bain qui
soutient qui soutient alain juppé et ça
passerait par héros parce que françois
bayrou a cette fois ci soutenu alain
juppé ça nous interdirait de le faire
vous entretenez des relations parfois
compliquées avec france avait ou là vous
allez vous retrouver dans un bateau une
seconde chance et alors mais moi c'est
un bon plat je suis pour une coalition
c'est à dire additionner des gens
différents aux parcours différents
c'est vrai des républicains c'est vrai
de lui des issas peut être vrai du modem
si tel est leur choix
ça peut être vrai de déçus du
hollandisme également je pense comme je
les dis ça me paraît beaucoup plus
importants que les petites
politicaillerie que nous avons besoin de
mettre dans une future majorité toutes
celles et tous ceux qui peuvent partager
des lignes politiques
pourquoi donc aller jusqu'à l'orage
vérité tous les déçus du hollandisme
sont également mais vous savez comment
vous construisez une majorité juste avec
les gens qui ont toujours voté pour vous
c'est bizarre parce que quand vous avez
perdu les élections
ça devient compliqué on a évolué dans le
cadre de cette coalition que vous
appelez de vos voeux ce qu'il faudrait
que le premier ministre alain juppé
souhaite un centriste non je crois que
le premier ministre doit être celui qui
est issu du rang des remparts dont du
parti de la plus grande majorité parce
que sinon le parti principal entre
guillemets fait vivre un enfer à
matignon est pour nous la question et
les discussions que nous avons eues avec
les candidats et avec un à juppé se sont
jamais posé en termes de postes
elles se sont posés en termes à la fois
de ligne politique et d'attitudes le
parti unique le seul qui a la majorité à
lui tout seul c'est à dire une petite
majorité rabougri dans le pays qui
ensuite se retrouve paralysée quand elle
veut transformer réformer ça c'est fini
la coalition c'est l'addition de force
pour justement émergents sur les
législatives non plus dans ce cas là on
n'y avait pas eu et il y en aura
évidemment après la primaire mais il y
en a pas eu
c'est pas loin de lui ou jours mais
attendez pardon on va pas faire passer
la boutique avant la france
il y aura besoin d'un équilibre dans une
majorité mais avant de parler d'
équilibre sur les hommes fallait déjà
trouvé un certain nombre d' équilibre
sur les idées merci merci nous asseyons
poursuit cette semaine des propos de
françois hollande ont mis les juges vent
debout dans un livre d'entretien le chef
de l'état dénonce la lâcheté des juges
c'est une humiliation répond la
profession à l'assemblée le ministre de
la justice a pris la défense du chef de
l'état écoutez je ressens monsieur le
ministre
une profonde émotion au moment où je
vous parle je vous parle à vous garder
chaud et sous le contrôle également
d'une ancienne garde des sceaux madame
lebranchu que je salue ici présents
monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui va sortir un livre dont le
titre est sûre le président ne devrais
pas dire ça
dans ce livre il est qu' il ya eu en son
temps le mur des cons aujourd'hui à le
mur des lâches
le président la république à traiter
l'institution judiciaire de l'acheter
il a accusé les magistrats de se
planquer de jouer les vertueux et il a
ajouté la justice n'aime pas la
politique c'est un véritable scandale de
chemise monsieur le député
donnez moi un mot un mot publique du
président de la république depuis 2012
dans lequel il aurait ne serait ce que
fait un commentaire sur une décision de
justice
pas un mot encore moins une insulte pas
un acte pas une demande d'intervention
pour interférer dans une procédure pas
un jugement portait pas un jugement
porté publiquement à l'occasion d'une
émission télévisée sur tel ou tel
magistrat est donc ce que vous avez dit
n'est pas corroborée par les faits et
par les actes posés par le président de
la république voté par cette majorité
quel est votre sentiment est ce que vous
pensez que françois hollande a vraiment
pu tenir ce type de propos et s'ils sont
vrais est-ce que c'est digne d'un
président de la république d'abord je
plains jean jacques urvoas parce que je
pense que c'est un honnête homme et
qu'il était dans un exercice très
difficile il a raison le président de la
république justement publiquement n'a
jamais rien dit elle mais ça monte aussi
ce qu'est françois hollande doit être ce
qu'il dit publiquement et ce qu'il dit à
des journalistes en confiance entre
guillemets dans son intimité ce qu'il
pense et c'est tout le problème de ce
quinquennat c'est clair de ce que je dis
est ce qu il a contesté
il n'a pas contesté est ce qu il a
contesté donc c'est qu'il l'a dit sinon
il dirait que c'est pas vrai et c'est
pas digne d'un pardon d'un c'est
évidemment un digne des chefs de l'état
d'abord ce qui est indigne d'un chef de
l'état c'est de passer mille heures de
sa fonction à s'occuper de lui parce que
finalement dans ce livre de quoi
parle-t-il
il parle de lui de ses femmes de ses
nuits à l'elysée de ses espoirs et de la
france il en parle quand ils s'occupent
de la france quand moi ce qui me choque
le plus c'est ça c'est une honte absolue
qu'un président de la république n'est
rien d'autre à faire que s'admiraient
innovants des une présidence normale
sans doute se croit-il tellement normal
qu'il fallait qu'il se regarde dans le
miroir et c'est ça ce livre je dis
simplement qu'à un moment donné il était
là pour exercer le pouvoir
il aime manifestement le pouvoir mais il
ne l'exercent país admire au pouvoir ça
explique l'état de la france je pense
très franchement que se livrent le
disqualifie totalement pour
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle à nouveau et je vais vous
dire je pense que la question devrait
être posée notamment au député
socialiste c'est à dire ils vont ils
vont vraiment soutenir ce président là
ils vont vraiment être candidat à
nouveau aux élections législatives pour
obtenir sa réélection est constitué sa
majorité
est-ce que vous chacun d'entre eux le
député a fait chacun d'entre eux a une
lourde responsabilité
j'en vois pas de message je pose une
question parce que à la sortie nous
avons tous des responsabilités et ses
responsabilités faut les assumer et
quand on soutient quelqu'un comme ça
pour la candidature à la présidence la
république avec un bilan catastrophique
un million de chômeurs de plus 600
milliards de dettes supplémentaires une
éducation par audrey c'est un délitement
social comme on en connaît et qu'en plus
il se montre indigne de la fonction
qu'en plus il met en cause une des
institutions qu'il est censé protéger
on peut être parlementaire militants
socialistes mais enfin à un moment donné
faut enlever les oeillères et penser un
peu plus à la france qu'au parti alors
parlons aussi des sujets de fond
je vous propose de poursuivre avec le
gros morceau législatives de l'automne
le budget 2010 est
il a été débattu toute la journée en
commission des finances et le dernier
budget du quinquennat le point sur les
mesures fiscales contenues dans ce
budget avec béatrice faisant après une
journée de débats jusque tard dans la
nuit
une commission des finances qui se vide
ce qu'il faut retenir du premier volet
du budget 2010 est tout d'abord la
baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est la
nouveauté est la priorité
figurant des l'article 2 du projet de
loi de finances 2010 cette bonne
nouvelle pour les classes moyennes soit
7 millions de foyers dont les impôts
seront réduits de 20% environ
l'autre annonce très attendue la
création d'une taxe youtube
l'amendement socialiste portés
farouchement par karine berger concerne
les géants du net
l'idée est de taxer les revenus générés
par la publicité sur tous les sites de
vidéos
les députés ont voté ce sera 2 % du
chiffre d'affaires des ventes et
abonnements l'argent ainsi récolté sera
redistribué au cnc le centre national du
cinéma
quant à l'optimisation fiscale les
députés ont cherché les moyens de la
limite et en taxant de nouveau les
fameuses actions gratuites en faveur des
patrons des grandes entreprises
fini donc la défiscalisation et les
salaires triplé qui vont avec
enfin la gauche désir et l'élargir mais
c'est la commission des finances qui a
eu le dernier mot
la taxe sur les transactions financières
ne sera pas augmenté en revanche un
quart de cet impôt servira à financer
l'aide publique au développement
un budget revu à la hausse donc mais un
net recul pour les ong
alors les députés ont alourdi la facture
fiscale des ménages est ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne idée
évidemment non faut dire que les députés
socialistes ont eu cette manie presque
cette obsession depuis le début à contre
emploi
son talent est fiscalisé par exemple les
retraités qui n'avait quasiment plus la
possibilité de payer leurs impôts ils
sont allés le faire sur les emplois
familiaux comme ça ils ont développé le
travail au noir ce qui tapent des
avantages des gens qui travaillaient
dans ce secteur parce qu'ils cotisent
plus pour la retraite parce qu'ils ont
plus de couverture maladie
ils ont matraqué en réalité le pays de
47 milliards d'impôts nouveaux
supplémentaires parti pour les
entreprises
parti pour les ménages donc tout le
monde a eu droit à son augmentation
d'impôts la question qu'on doit se poser
c'est qu'avec 47 milliards
d'augmentation d'impôts est ce qu'ils
ont réduit réellement le déficit
on sait c'est un âge là la réponse aux
déficits la réponse est non on en parle
de déficit allons-y
parce que dans le débat des républicains
et de la droite et du centre
et la question a été posée est-ce que
vous allez laisser filer les déficits
pendant tout le quinquennat suivant si
la droite remporte il n'y a pas eu de
réponse sur les déficits vous l'européen
et vous sur la règle des 3%
j'imagine que ça dit quoi sert donc dû
quand même vous choquer pardon quand
j'entends alain juppé expliquer qu'on
fait 80 à 100 milliards d'euros
d'économie sur un quinquennat ce qui est
une des raisons d'ailleurs pour lesquels
il faut allonger la durée du travail
dans le trou d'air la retraite entre
autres des amis des arts c'est une part
substantielle
je pense que il répond à la question
nous avons besoin de baisser nos
dépenses publiques
si on veut avoir les règles des sciences
val si on veut avoir mais oui tout à
fait et si on veut avoir la possibilité
de respecter cette règle est de
retrouver un équilibre responsable si
cette génération acceptent de payer ses
factures plutôt que de refiler à ses
gosses
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
pardon revenant son budget aujourd'hui
c'est un budget invraisemblable de fin
de mandat bidon et fantoche simple
depuis simard en soit hollande françois
hollande depuis le mois exactement face
il n'en restera la facture qu'il va
falloir qu'on paye ah pardon hélas
françois hollande a engagé des dépenses
nouvelles
au moment où on parle de faire des
économies engagées entre 12 et 15
milliards de dépenses qui pour 9
milliards vont peser cette année et que
pour le reste vont peser chaque année en
2018 en 2019 en 2020
il en est même à faire de la cavalerie
budgétaire en demandant par exemple
l'acompte de l'impôt sur les sociétés
par avance sur 2018 ont fait de la
cavalerie et dans le même temps monsieur
sapin madame thorel arrivent en disant
nous avons un bilan formidable tout va
bien l'économie les 2,7 mais on se fout
de nous madame touraine a le culot de
dire que
le budget de la sécurité sociale est en
équilibre alors qu'il ya 4,2 milliards
de déficit faut vraiment être socialiste
pour considérer que 4,2 milliards de
déficit
c'est un équilibre et qu'en plus les
seules raisons cet équilibre c'est
dommage d'ailleurs que dans le débat
hier il n'est pas suffisamment appelé
c'est la réforme de 2010 sur les
retraites que nous avons faite puisque
ce moment oui mais ceux qui justement
alors c'est justement ce que madame
touraine dans cet hémicycle à
l'assemblée nationale contesté ce sur
quoi ils s'étaient avec monsieur
hollande engagé à revenir ils sont
parvenus besoins seules économies guen
défaite c'est pas moi toute la campagne
pour en parler mais nous on va s'arrêter
avant de terminer sur cette émission sur
un thème de société c'est le cannabis
un colloque a eu lieu au sénat avec de
nombreux parlementaires de nombreuses
associations
regardez ce reportage étonnant débat
juste après que jean christophe lagarde
faut-il légaliser le cannabis le débat
est relancé par esther benbassa la
sénatrice écologiste souhaite faire
bouger les lignes dans une classe
politique française en décalage avec la
réalité
selon un sondage ipsos 84% des français
jugent la législation actuelle
inefficace pour limiter le trafic et la
consommation
52 % seraient favorables à la vente du
cannabis sous le contrôle de l'état
aujourd'hui c'est vrai la population
l'opinion publique a avancé davantage
que les politiciens qui sont encore dans
les tabous si je parle de cannabis y si
je défends cette idée est née je vais
perdre des voix non et comme d'habitude
les politiciens sont en retard par
rapport à l'évolution de la population
il faut sortir du tabou on peut pas
faire de la prévention pour ceux qui
n'existent pas pour l'association sos
addiction l'état gagnerait à autoriser
le cannabis à condition de créer une
autorité qui encadrerait et contrôlerez
strictement le marché
il va pas suffire de légaliser pour
faire un programme sanitaire et social
digne de ce nom d'où l'importance de
dieu du chantier légaliser va permette
de travail est un travail de longue
haleine et des avantages pour l'état la
france compte plus de quatre millions de
consommateurs annuel
le cannabis pourrait donc devenir une
source de revenus est un moyen de briser
une économie souterraine géré par les
mafias du rsa flag à 2 52% des français
favorables à la vente du cannabis
légalisé en tout cas encadré vous avez
aussi vous une position qui est pour
cette légalisation
c'est une position dont je reconnais
bien volontiers qu elle est individuelle
qu'elle n'est pas partagé par mon parti
mais qu'est ce qui est ancien je lui ai
même écrit dans un livre en 2007 s'agit
pas de légaliser ses dires de rendre
possible il faut encadrer donné dans un
monopole d'état
la vente du cannabis parce que première
chose si vous ne le faites pas en
réalité ce sont des mafias s'est dit à
la fin du reportage qui en profitent des
mafias dans les banlieues et des mafias
à l'extérieur y compris des mafias
terroristes qui nous combattent alimenté
avec notre argent avec la consommation
de cannabis des gens qui nous font la
guerre ou qui ne respectent pas nos lois
est une folie deuxième raison j'observe
simplement quand on est toujours sur une
posture morale on dit attention hein
c'est pas bien le cannabis mais cette
question là tout le monde est d'accord
évidemment que c'est pas bon pour les
gens évidemment que c'est pas bon pour
la santé
sauf que en ayant maintenu
l'interdiction depuis si longtemps
nous sommes un des pays où on consomme
le plus de cannabis on consomme plus de
cannabis en france alors que c'est
interdit que dans les pays où ce ne
l'est pas et troisième chose si on en
fait un monopole d'état
l'argent ainsi collecté plutôt que
d'aller aux mafias on utilise
massivement pour la prévention notamment
je veux que pas un seul enfant de notre
pays à plusieurs reprises dans ses
classes en primaire au collège au lycée
n'est comment des âges puissent sortir
sans avoir eu un enseignement sur les
dangers du cannabis et des autres
drogues
je pense qu'il est préférable en
l'occurrence de combattre en expliquant
d'un côté et en évitant que ce soit des
mafias parce que pour l'instant il n'y a
pas une ville y'a pas un village de
france où quelqu'un qui veut fumer du
cannabis ne sais pas vous recevrez un
sujet tabou c'est quelque chose un des
wagons pour la campagne je pense que
c'est un débat je pense que c'est un
débat qui de toute façon comme souvent
en france demandent du temps de la
maturation mais que les français avaient
longtemps auriez fait en 2007 vous
auriez fait monsieur le sondage 80%
d'enseignants pour s'en servir c'est un
marronnier effectivement mais parce que
la société française sur ce genre de
sujet a besoin de mûrir
est-ce qu'on peut juste s'interroger sur
le fait qu'il y a plus de gens qui se
droguent en france avec le cannabis que
dans les pays où il est légalement
autorisée chez nous c'est interdit il ya
plus de consommateurs savez il ya deux
anglais c'est soit un problème de
sécurité et là y'a pas photo évidemment
qu'il faut casser les mafias soit un
problème de santé publique
mais même quand c'est un problème de
santé publique on s'aperçoit en réalité
que l'interdiction ça fait plus de
consommateurs et de l'organisation et
ben c'est le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup jean christophe lagarde
merci jacques la semaine prochaine